President Trump says a ban on most
flavored vaping products is the right
response to what health officials call
an epidemic of e-cigarette use by
teenagers a recent surge in illnesses
possibly linked to vaping has grabbed
the attention of lawmakers regulators
and parents - including the President
and First Lady a survey taken last year
showed about one in five high school
students used e-cigarettes that's more
than three million kids 78 percent more
than the year before more than
two-thirds of those teenage vapors used
flavored products Paula Reid is at the
White House Paula why is the president
taking on this issue now Anthony the
president has faced pressure from the
public even his own wife to do something
about e-cigarettes and even if this
recent spike in lung related illnesses
is actually a combination of substances
like vaping and THC the administration
says it wants to target flavored
products because those are the ones most
appealing to kids it's very dangerous
children have died people have died with
First Lady Melania Trump sitting by his
side President Trump announced he wants
to take action to combat vaping but we
can't allow people to get sick and we
can't have our youth be so affected the
health and human services secretary
announced the FDA will soon issue
guidance on how to take flavored vaping
products off the market targeting items
they believe are especially appealing to
kids we simply have to remove these
attractive flavored products from the
marketplace until they secure FDA
approval
in a rare foray into public policy the
first lady has expressed her concern
about this issue on Twitter she's got a
son together that is a beautiful young
man and she feels very very strongly
about it but CBS News has learned any
real crackdown is likely a long way off
since it will take weeks for the FDA to
release its final rule and even then
companies have time to respond
there'll be legal challenges because
this is a big market dr. Elizabeth
Rosenthal the editor in chief of kaiser
Health News
says that could delay any real change
they're going to have pressure from the
health advocates
one side and from industry on the other
to do something and trying to walk that
line is gonna be really tough
the CEO of jewel the biggest ISA
Guerette company in the u.s. spoke with
Tony to copal last month what do you say
to those families those parents about
their teens using this product as I've
said this before I'm sorry that their
kids are using the product but there's
never an intent on the company's part to
target youth in a statement jewel says
we strongly agree with the need for
aggressive category wide action on
flavored products we will fully comply
with the final FDA policy when effective
now the FDA would still allow tobacco
flavored e-cigarettes for adults trying
to wean themselves off of other tobacco
products Tony and of course traditional
cigarettes would still be on the market
Paula thank you very much